josh is with us in Roanoke Virginia hi
Josh welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up hey Dave I just won does let
you know that I've been following your
program now for the past two months and
just wanted to say that I'm on a solid
two and a half year plane you can see
how to dance beat that free and I'm very
excited about it good for you basically
my question is today I've been trying to
follow more principles with the Bible
not only just about life but also about
money as well and also what if you've
been teaching and basically my question
is how can I work on getting out of debt
and also be generous and give back to
others at the same time well it
obviously they obviously both pull at
the same checkbook without a doubt and
scripture breaks giving in for those of
us that are Christians into two
categories tithing which is a tenth of
your income and offer tithes and
offerings there's not an instance that
I've been able to find in scripture that
an offering was given except from
surplus meaning extra money after you've
gotten yourself out of debt and you're
building some wealth and that even
includes the example the Widow's mite we
can discuss that another time if you go
through the legacy journey you'll see
some different renderings on that
scripture and look at it but anyway even
if you set that in there if you said the
Widow's mite is one time then that's the
only time in scripture that anybody gave
from anything except surplus other than
the tithe now every time the tithe is
mentioned a tenth of your income it's
called first fruits which means off the
top the first fruits that come out of
the harvest go to the Lord's house
before you do anything else and so the
baseline that I've used is this first
and foremost God's not mad at you in
either way he's your dad he's your
heavenly Father he loves you he thinks
you're awesome
he thinks you're smart he's not going to
be
she's not gonna wait to give you good
things until you do it exactly perfect
according to him it's not all that
freaked out okay so let's not get
legalistic about performance based
Christianity okay we're not going to do
that so we're gonna walk we're gonna
walk in grace and in the light and with
a lot of love and we're just
everything's gonna be okay and we're
gonna say so the tithe is a principle it
is not a sin issue okay and people get
that people get them confused they make
them very very legalistic I don't i'm
very diligent about it but i'm not
legalistic about it so because i'm very
sure that my dad who loves me put his
arm around me and says son the best way
to live is with your money the first
thing you do is you give ten percent to
your local church then here's some other
stuff you do with money if you want to
win with money but he's gonna love me
whether I do it or not you follow me
yeah okay so the tithe is your baseline
you start there no matter how broke you
are ten percent but I wouldn't give a
dime more than that and I didn't i tithe
though all the way in the Bankruptcy
Court and all the way out and so I mean
I've tied my whole Christian life ever
since I got saved and met God and so I
believe you give a tenth of your income
and evangelicals have taught that for
hundreds and hundreds of years that our
grasp of the scripture is that we give a
tenth of our income to our local church
because it's a New Testament
representation of the Old Testament
storehouse the storehouse took care of
the widows and the orphans and fed the
priests the Levites so the local
churches job is to take care of the
widows and orphans and pay the pastor
that's their primary job so be it being
active in the community taking care of
single moms loving on widows and
children and you know that kind of stuff
and being if your church is doing that
you're attending that church you trust
that church the in that you shouldn't
attend there if you don't trust them and
you get in you give them a tent and then
other giving I would wait to do until I
got my self out of debt got my emergency
fund in place
at that point when I'm doing baby steps
4 5 & 6 I would increase some of my
generosity at that point and of course
you're gonna really increase it when you
get to baby step 7 above 10% but I kind
of break them into those two buckets not
kind of I do now again you can do
whatever you want but that's how I have
interpreted Scripture absolutely that
helps us tremendously I was really
pardon to me and I was really appreciate
the insight on that cool thank you for
calling in man I appreciate you
listening open phones at Triple Eight 8
to 5 5 2 to 5 by the way a lot of you
that are listening are not people of
faith I understand that that guy was
asking me from that perspective so I'm
answering from that perspective if
you're not you still ought to apply the
principle is the principle will still
work for you
the principle is give something 10% is
not a bad guideline and get you know
give 10% and then do your budget with
the other 90% you'll make it you'll make
it and something is activated in you
when you're giving that that says okay
I'm not it's not all about me I'm not
gonna try to squeeze every penny until
it screams I'm gonna hold this with an
open hand this is not all about some
weirdness but you can't grit your teeth
enough and and there's something that
happens when you when you learn to give
that it moves you along the selfishness
spectrum from selfish to less selfish
and for those of us that are believers
that's why God tells you to do that he's
trying to teach you a lesson not cuz he
needs your money
he didn't need your money if he wants
your money he'd take it there'll be a
greasy spot where you were sitting he
doesn't need your money he's got money
he's God okay
so and if his church needed his money
he'd get it for somebody other than you
don't worry about it that's not the
problem
the problem is he's trying to teach you
how to win and how to be a better person
on how to grow and in our case again
people of faith be more like Christ more
christ-like more like God and so become
better grow in your spiritual walk and
that's that's where giving comes in
and that's why we say live like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else because giving is the most
fun you will ever have with money by far
nothing comes close now you can go out
and have a 300 dollar dinner at a
fine-dining establishment with some of
the world's best food and wine and you
should I want you to get the point that
you can do that but you can also have
more fun than that with that 300 bucks
giving it away finding someone that you
learn a little bit about their
situations so you're not giving a drunk
a drink we're not going to be an enabler
but we find a situation and you know
you're been a situation where three
hours to change your life I have I've
been that broke I've been that scared
and you just catch somebody just as
they're leaning over just as they're
about to fall over and you had them 300
bucks it changes everything it's like
stand straight back up it's it's it's
amazing and it's my friend Chris Brown
says that generosity works like this if
you do not position yourself for your
intentions you cannot do your intentions
you can intend to be helpful you can
intend to be giving but when you get
yourself in good shape financially then
you're positioned for your intentions
and you can be generous then and that
that's a that's a beautiful thing
intending there's a lot of people intend
to do stuff but if you intend to send
your wife flowers on your anniversary
but you don't you don't get points for
your intention you only get points if
you sent the freaking flowers okay I
don't care what you intend to do or what
your heart says or how you feel about
something what you actually do is what
you get points for right she's not
keeping score oh I know you meant to do
that it's okay now that didn't how that
works darling
the flowers actually need to hit the
table baby they got to show up at the
front door with a little man from the
florist that's how that works
intention doesn't matter you got to do
it I intended I don't care what
I care what you did that's how you
measure that so put yourself in a
position to be outrageously generous and
quit talking about it we're talking
about everybody else being generous when
you're not man there's some people doing
that isn't